how do i level up my emotional physical
and mental state to bring all of those
three of those up okay cool that's
actually something that i actually
totally
can relate to because my entire motto of
life okay so let me just say something
i wake up every morning expect other
than days where i have a podcast and i
have to be out the door about like
[ __ ] 6 a.m and drive from miami to
fort lauderdale i don't really have time
to do that but most days
i wake up and i do yoga and i do an
affirmation and i get mental clarity and
i always say what i'm grateful for and
that i'm happy to be alive
and that um my body is healthy my mind
is focused and my heart and soul are in
the right place i say this to myself i
say this to myself i say this myself
and i say that i am focused on three
things my health my wealth and my
happiness okay let's break that down yes
health wealth happiness health wealth
happiness and i'm constantly giving
myself a score
one through ten of my health my wealth
and my happiness i'm proud to say that i
haven't been below at eight on any of
those in a very long time very proud but
but it's not a tent always my health
health comes first health comes first
without health you have nothing what do
i mean by health am i exercising am i
eating well do i look good am i feeling
good like
am i am i sick am i not sick have i not
gotten sleep where's my health at okay
cool you know i had covet i wouldn't say
that i was eight so that was two years
ago i had coveted but i'm constantly
saying all right bro
you're at an eight and you're definitely
closer to a seven than a nine you need
to hit the gym dude i'm constantly
saying that wealth cool
luckily i've had money in my life for
quite some time now went from broke as a
joke to
to chilling uh but uh but there's levels
to this game of wealth and i'm
constantly saying all right where am i
at wealth-wise here's the big kicker
though happiness what's happiness
everyone wants to be happy
in my opinion happiness stems from
having meaning and purpose in your life
and doing things towards that
having meaning and purpose in your life
is what creates happiness one time i
went to this event called the
international day of happiness it was a
big happiness event happiness event
they're teaching people how to be happy
it was a big day happy
and my boy jamie actually puts it on and
they said that um
they're able to scientifically track
happiness i said all right go on
and they said that like some people find
happiness in
um you know buying things that they
really like and they scientifically said
that it's basically the
equivalent of a sugar high so let's say
you like shoes you went and bought shoes
you put the shoes on you're like i'm
killing it i love my shoes
scientifically three days later you're
back to the same level you were that's
true okay but if you do something like
something that i've done so many times
that i'm an advocate of if you do
something
for other people you know they say it's
better to give them receive so instance
i used to go to the special olympics
every year of my life really okay have
you ever been to the special olympics oh
my god we're going this year okay so all
my friends out there if you've never
been to the special olympics you have a
completely different outlook on life
once you go to the special olympics
these people this is the biggest day of
their life and these people have
conditions you couldn't [ __ ] worse
wish on your worst enemy and you see
these people who can barely walk and
they're in a wheelchair or they've got
cerebral palsy or they've got mental
disorders they've got
all sorts of situations going on
and they're in a race and whether they
finish in first place or last place and
they finish the race they are the
happiest people
on earth and you know your role that you
have you have a role you know your job
that day is the people that go and
volunteer
the title of the volunteer you're called
a hugger
okay your job at the end of the day is
to give them a hug at the end of the
race wow and you just go and they're
like oh my god
and you're like oh i'm so proud of you
and it's like
and scientifically three days later
you're still almost as happy as you were
three days prior so i'm giving you an
example of
what it's like buying a material item
three days later sugar how you're gone
right but three days after you just
volunteered to the special olympics you
still have basically a large chunk of it
in your heart
so what i'm talking about of happiness
is that having meaning and purpose in
your life and doing things towards that
that is what makes you happy yeah okay
so every day like people if they don't
know if they know this i have a full on
other financial career for financial
firm hedge fund i do that but i do this
because it gives me meaning and purpose
and i have friends here and i have great
love of being a part of environment i've
been a mentor in pbd and that has that's
given me
meaning and purpose in my life
insurance finance that's what i do but
it's not who i am this
is more who i am so if you can find that
meaning and purpose and work towards
that that's where you'll find your
happiness so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire sauce cast
click right here
[Music]